- So the question is, does section three
of the 14th Amendment
apply to President Trump,
in the sense that it bars people
who have committed sedition
from holding office
in the United States?
Putting aside the question
of whether President Trump
actually committed sedition or not,
the 14th Amendment, this particular clause
was enabled to prevent members
of the Confederacy from holding office
in the federal government again.
And for better or worse,
this section of the 14th Amendment
has almost never been used
because almost as soon
as Congress passed it,
they granted a waiver to almost everyone
that served for the
South in the Civil War.
And there are tons of open questions
in terms of whether
this is self-executing,
whether you actually have to hold a trial.
And we just don't know the answer
to these questions right now.
So it's a completely open
question if it applies
to President Trump and
to what extent it does.
So stay tuned for& more election coverage
and I'll see you in court.